[Music]
you're from los angeles
yes you were living in new york city
last couple of years then you moved back
here was there anything that you sort of
forgot about
l.a i mean here you are living in new
york and then you moved back here was
there anything
that you suddenly realized oh i forgot
this part of your life well i forgot
that there's room in
there's space yeah right right i got the
opposite of claustrophobic
in in la i got like rheumaphobic i was
like there's too much room
right there's too much diamonds because
no no but no but it is true that in new
york you really get used to
eating a sandwich with someone else's
face right
here eating a different sandwich and you
don't know that person and your cheek
and their cheek are right up against
each other
and you're eating sandwiches and then
here you actually see someone from
across the room
then you really see how they eat a
sandwich exactly like that's gross the
way you eat that exactly yeah i kind of
like that yeah
so but no also wildlife i remember i got
into this house which i'm no longer
living in because
for various reasons but um but one of
them was there's this massive snake as i
was
going down my front porch it was this it
was enormous
and i i literally almost stepped on it
and my two little dogs i only have one
now it's not sad
the other one died um probably eaten by
the snake i'm guessing
you said there's a giant snake i had two
dogs and now i haven't had one
i'm doing the math in my what could have
happened
snake's like i got that so
we you so no i mean i really am sad
about that but um
no the uh sorry me too
but no i did i did have an encounter
with the massive snake and actually the
owners of the house called the fire
department
and apparently they went and took it
away and i don't know whether it was
poisonous the fire department came and
took the snake well you know l.a it's
like
right i've never encountered a snake out
here i think you brought a picture of
the snake because this is pretty
important
that is a real i don't know what kind of
snake that is do you know what kind it
is is that a poisonous snake
well i i basically just didn't want to
find out right um i just said please
take it away
right um so yeah i think i think the
encounter with with wildlife was sort of
um i a little cat who uh decided she was
she's an indoor cat and she suddenly
just disappeared for
for like two days and i thought a coyote
took her and was just saying things are
going terribly wrong here in l.a
um and uh and she kept like hiding in
weird places i searched everywhere
and then i basically climbed on the roof
to see if she was somehow in the chimney
and lo and behold i have a picture of
that too
she was in the chimney you found her in
the oh my god
do you know you got her out okay i
assume yeah yeah i could have been like
that woman who got stuck in the chimney
you know
going to get her cats yes that's amazing
look at that it's
such a cute i mean that's either a cat
or the devil
those are your choices get out this
is my portal
but you got your cat out okay got my cat
out i did have to climb up and and get
her out but good for you you took charge
you could have lowered the snake and
gotten well